for some people horror films metal music
or sexually themed art are morally fine
to create or
enjoy wrong put a point up baby let's go
uh the or is what does it for yes
sexually themed yeah I mean it shouldn't
be pornography but but sexually themed
is obviously fine of course and horror
films are not horror films I think can
be can be quite good there's some great
hor the exception to me if it had been
an and my answer probably would have
been no because metal music metal music
I don't think is actually defensible I
you know I know so little about metal
music it just the sound of it sounds
just the name of it sounds ter what I
know of it comes from Plato okay and was
he a big metal guy he was a huge metal
fan actually yeah it was with like the
bakas balaclavas bakala no hold on I'm
That's The Salted sea bass God